ça y est je vais vous poser quelques
questions tout commence par un petit
questionnaire taille poids antécédents
et régime alimentaire
autant d'éléments qui permettent de
déterminer le risque d'être diabétique
place ensuite aux tests à l'aide d'un
glucomètre l'appareil permet de mesurer
le taux de glucose dans le sang en
dessous de à g 10 si on n'a pas eu de
repas à moins de deux heures
la certitude qu'il y a sept cent mille
personnes qui sont diabétiques et qu'ils
l'ignorent parce que c'est une maladie
sourde perte de vue infections les
symptômes n'apparaissent réellement qu'à
un stade avancé de la maladie lui rps
mène donc depuis trois ans une campagne
de dépistage du diabète en ile de france
cette année le groupement de pharmaciens
pharma vie a permis d'élargir cette
opération à toute la france
on est à un petit peu plus de 1000
personnes qui ont été en tout cas
dépistés et sur les 1000 il ya une
soixantaine de personnes qui ont une
semie sub normal et qui ont été donc
adressée auprès du médecin le diabète et
c'est une cause nationale donc l'idée
étant de de sensibiliser les personnes
partout en france et donc nous avons
incité l'ensemble du réseau a participé
à ces journées donc nous avons à l'heure
actuelle plus de 100 pharmacie qui
participent à ces dépistages plus de
deux millions et demi de francs 16 sont
atteints de diabète
parmi les personnes à risque celle de
plus de 45 ans celle en surpoids ayant
un diabétique dans la famille ou les
femmes ayant eu du diabète lors d'une
grossesse dans les yvelines il est
possible de se faire dépister à
guyancourt où dans rambouillet jusqu'au
30 novembre